second show was in Copenhagen in Denmark
I mean are we basing that just off the
hot dog yes
triple had
um
Thai food
which actually was some of the best Thai
food I've had not in Thailand that was
insane it was very wholesome I was like
can you can you can you talk Ty to them
I think that the woman over there is
Thai yeah no because you don't
understand right when you go to a
restaurant that there's Thai outside of
Thailand and the staff of Thai if they
know that one of you speaks Thai it's
just a different restaurant oh yeah it's
just a different it's a different meal
and so I think this is I think anyone
from like southeast Asia or maybe he's
like even like the South American
countries can like relate to this but so
you know the person running the
restaurant was uh kind of like a Thai
Auntie kind of thing you know
um you know she was you know obviously
an older Thai woman and oh we've come in
we start off speaking English you know
she gives us the normal treatment uh and
then as soon as I start speaking Thai
she goes on full Auntie mode all right
she she and uh because I was I I asked
her inside yo I'm looking to you know
show my friends some good Thai food uh
do you like I was thinking of ordering
this this this and she goes okay one
thing about Asian uh especially South
East Asian like aunties we anyone who's
been to a family gathering knows the men
don't run ship it's it is the aunties
that call the shots okay you may think
the men run things in Southeast Asia no
once the aunties want to do something
they are getting it done yeah they are
they are the secret mafia boss so I was
like I'm thinking you're ordering this
this and she goes no no no no no I'll
order for you you need this this this
this and this it was all really good
yeah yeah and it was it was insane yeah
yeah yeah yeah we also had we went to
some other kind of I think which was
like a Danish restaurant where it was
like lamb yeah yeah that's right some
other stuff it was pretty good I
honestly you guys said asked here I
think hot dogs are carrying it but I
think it's a I think it's a too no the
hot dogs I asked here 100 agree if we
have a separate category I don't know
man that lamb was pretty dope it was
good and I feel like we had better meals
all right well actually we didn't all
share the same meals though as well that
is true yeah no I I still think I'm
still sticking it I I'm sticking with
Esther uh you may say the hot dogs are
carrying but I'm happy for hot dogs to
Solo Carry those are those are
life-changing I cannot have an American
hot dog ever again because I'm just
gonna be thinking how how much better
the Danish hot dogs are listen I I think
the Costco hot dog has a soft spot in my
heart get the [__] out it's 1.50 for the
combo why are you saying the Costco hot
dogs are better no no no the Danish
lizards I did not say that I said it had
a soft spot in my heart because they're
cheap I can't I can't go back man okay
question that question then okay did you
have a better meal than in Denmark was
there a meal that you had like don't
tell me where but do you think you had a
meal that was better than Denmark too
many s tears a meal that was better than
Denmark in your head for you Joe uh uh
no okay gone uh I have one that was
equal okay okay I know which one it is
okay yeah yeah
after Denmark you went to Amsterdam
right yeah yeah
look at that beautiful Glizzy look at
that yeah look how long then uh one
dollar
too much
like it's a one dollar fifty hot dog man
come on where are the toppings man that
looks naked compared to some of the
dinosaurs there is a topping station
guys did you know that if the hot dog uh
Costco was had gone with inflation as in
like when it was originally priced at
1.50 it should be like four dollars
fifty something yeah didn't didn't the
Costco hot dog go up in price at one
point no no the CEO or the CEO or one of
them was in a meeting and was like I
will kill you if you raise the price of
the hot dog
it was it was experience great he was
like you will not rate because they lose
money on the hot dogs yeah yeah which is
which I I just love that that they're
like
foreign
[Music]
dogs is that there's not just one you
have like so many different varieties as
well you have some of the spicy hot dogs
the bacon wrapped hot dogs yeah you know
the the usual hot dogs as well the thin
hot dogs there are there's just so much
choice I don't know how this is even an
argument that's a Ford that's such value
that you get with the Costco hot dog how
can you bet again four dollars it should
cost it hasn't changed since the 80s
isn't that crazy
years of value that's just beaten
inflation yeah I just absolutely you
know I mean I think that them keeping
that price at 1.50 has done more good PR
for Costco than anything else oh 100
okay okay so after that we went to
Amsterdam or Rotterdam and then
Amsterdam yeah so yeah this is a little
bit biased because this is the only
country where we did two shows in I
don't remember the meals I had yeah yeah
actually no we uh you know despite the
French best croissant of my life I had
it really yeah yeah actually I agree it
was serious [__] because we were sitting
down in the cafe and we could smell the
grass once and we were like oh could we
get one of those she's like oh it takes
30 minutes but it's baked to order yeah
and I was like okay Jesus Christ I had
uh the best I can't remember what it's
called what's the one where it's like a
poached egg and Hollandaise sauce
eggs benedict of my life really
Amsterdam yeah
there's one core memory I have for it
though I'm calling you out Nabi Nabi we
were in the we were in this Cafe right
yeah and it was kind of it was kind of
slow uh and um but this is just like one
thing you can never do in European
restaurants yeah you can't do it which
you do do in Japanese restaurants right
so we're sitting down and you know we I
was on a bit of a time crunch uh and uh
we're just kind of trying to get their
attention and then that'd be goes from
across the Russian goes excuse me
yeah yeah and you can see me and Connor
just recorded every coil into our seats
like this and like no it would only make
it worse by the fact that she goes yes
I'm coming
at most you can do the half hand right
yeah just like the way the way we do it
in Europe is you awkwardly wait for like
eye contact and you're just like excuse
me it's a very inefficient just yeah we
could do with the Sumo sound but I think
people would abuse it yeah that's true
but I think the croissants would helped
and I okay I've been to France a lot
that was the best craft song I've ever
had in my life okay you're not gonna lie
I don't remember a single meal are you
waiting at CT then or BTS Like I can't
even rate it I don't remember anything I
ate I had a had something called um wild
beer what wild beer I went to this uh
Cafe I thought it was for food but I
guess it was beer and I kind of felt
pressured into getting a beer because
the guy was like we don't have anything
but beer I was like okay uh it was a
cafe uh so I was like okay because you
have coffee he's like no just beer
um and he he was like do you want
something basic he said the word basic
okay or do you want something
interesting so yeah it's I guess it's
kind of like this yeah it's pulling it
up now it's like this it wasn't like a
brand it was like a style of beer and I
knew it was kind of weird when he
brought out a glass bottle and had a
cork in it what and he Uncorked the beer
and it tastes like wine and it was like
nine percent uh it was extremely sour
um
he was trying to explain to me what it
was I I couldn't I couldn't for the life
of you tell me it sounded like it was
like yeah we just throw it in the casket
and then we opened it up
that's wild looking yeah I don't know
yeah maybe maybe I don't know what on
Earth it was
yeah it just keeps coming up the same
thing yeah I have no idea how to it was
it was yeah he said it was like they
have it in like a keg and they bottle it
and put it in a cork it was so
interesting I do though remember
actually it's not a meal but I do
remember a cool memory uh because we
went to McDonald's
I'm not saying anything it's up to you
guys but like the one core memory I had
was like it was it was me and a bunch of
the crew and we were like you know what
let's just go get something really quick
because you know we're not even that
hungry just a quick bite to eat we we
saw a McDonald's I was five minutes down
the road and obviously you know because
it's Amsterdam right like every street
has bike lanes and everyone's biking
everywhere and I don't know what these
like kids problems were but there were
two kids on bikes that were just like
constantly circling the block that we
were on and then out of nowhere they
just threw like a Twix bar at us
like straight up like this kid on a bike
had like I don't know if you had like a
box of Twix or something like in his
backpack but he just like pulled one out
and just pegged it at us he hit Sarah on
the head on the head and then Mike and
Guy our staff were just like I'm gonna
[__] kill those kids and uh yeah
that's the only thing I remember about
Amsterdam oh that's that's funny because
uh when we were in Copenhagen it's funny
that you know generally Danish people
seem pretty chill they were like very
very polite and chill one of like the
politest shows we've had uh which
doesn't say much about Europe because
everyone there is polite
um and everyone's chill except when you
[__] up on the bike lane I I it's if you
don't know the exact bike etiquette I've
never had so much abuse thrown at me
just my passing cyclist to be like they
do it in such a calm demeanor as well
you know it's never like a shout or like
a like like a big exaggeration it's just
you know if like I had that once where
like I almost [__] ran into another
cyclist because I didn't realize that oh
there's red lights for bikes yeah in
Denmark and I didn't see that I ran
through almost hit a guy and as I was
passing through him in the Karma's voice
he was just like what the [__]
so I just like slowly slowed down right
and I thought that was like the escort
just like don't stop a minute you just
like slow down and come to a stop and
then as I do I I haven't I ordered a
Dutch woman just like psycho boss me and
just go [__] I don't like whoa what
it's so fun it's because they're so
chill it feels so bad yeah it's it's the
way it's the chill way they say it you
know if if they shout out to me I'll
just be like it's the passive
aggressiveness yeah yeah yeah for sure
all right well I have no room to rate uh
Netherlands food because I had
McDonald's purely not remembering
anything other than a croissant I'm just
gonna put it in C just because something
needs to go and see all right
um do you agree with that guy
we have to thin this out because we
can't just put everything in snakes as a
cop out uh Wales is well well well this
is what else is this moments all right
I'm biased yeah you know as much as we
uh you guys big up the leak soup right
yeah battle breathe goes hard but you
don't have to eat that that's fine